-Performing "Memory Lane"
from his album, "Multiverse",
please welcome Wiz Khalifa.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ When the days turn
to nights ♪
♪ I keep thinking
'bout you moving on ♪
♪ Makes me wonder if you hear
this song, yeah ♪
♪ Would you right the way
that we went wrong? ♪
♪ Yeah, when the days
turn to nights ♪
♪ That's when I begin
to lose it all ♪
♪ Makes me wonder if you hear
this song ♪
♪ Would you right the way
that we went wrong? ♪
-♪ Played it for you instead
of running game on you ♪
♪ Kept it 100,
I expect the same from you ♪
♪ Held it down for me every time
them lames come through ♪
♪ Said they was down
to do the things I did ♪
♪ But they ain't want to ♪
♪ Now every time it come on,
you get uncomfortable ♪
♪ Been a couple years since you
left, you see how time flew ♪
♪ You been on my mind every day,
I'm on your mind too ♪
♪ Make me think about all the
things that I survived through ♪
♪ I be ridin' 'round by myself,
but that's what pride do ♪
♪ Got you thinking 'bout what
you said and how it's not true ♪
♪ There you go
with the memories ♪
♪ The reason the ego's
the worst enemy ♪
-♪ When the days turn
to nights ♪
♪ I keep thinking 'bout you
moving on ♪
♪ Makes me wonder if you hear
this song, yeah ♪
♪ Would you right the way
that we went wrong? ♪
♪ Yeah, when the days turn
to nights ♪
♪ That's when I begin
to lose it all ♪
♪ Makes me wonder
if you hear this song ♪
♪ Would you right the way
that we went wrong? ♪
-♪ It's funny how one play ♪
♪ Could put you in the mood
for the day ♪
♪ A good one or a bad one
depending on where you stay ♪
♪ Just let me know
if it's safe ♪
♪ 'Cause we done did things
that we can't erase ♪
♪ And eff the team I brought ♪
♪ I gave you game
that you can't replace ♪
♪ You came up in a major way ♪
♪ Quit moving out of fear,
started moving out of faith ♪
♪ You told me that you heard our
favorite song the other day ♪
♪ First, you was trying
to leave ♪
♪ Now you say you on your way ♪
♪ That's the price to pay ♪
♪ I guess that's
what love cost ♪
♪ Just 'cause you walked out the
door don't mean the love lost ♪
-♪ When the days
turn to nights ♪
♪ I keep thinking 'bout you
moving on ♪
♪ Makes me wonder if you hear
this song, yeah ♪
♪ Would you right the way that
we went wrong? ♪
♪ Yeah, when the days turn
to nights ♪
♪ That's when I begin
to lose it all ♪
♪ Makes me wonder if you hear
this song ♪
♪ Would you right the way that
we went wrong? ♪
-♪ Seen it at a concert,
you called off work ♪
♪ Even bought the shirt ♪
♪ Was glad we was there
for the crowd surf ♪
♪ We said that night,
we both found our purpose ♪
♪ Had both our hands going
in circles ♪
♪ Listened over and over ♪
♪ Trying to find out
what the words was ♪
♪ It came from a band
we never heard of ♪
♪ But now it's the soundtrack
to our life ♪
♪ Rolled up all day to it,
ride all night ♪
♪ Every time we turn it on,
people say all kind of things ♪
♪ Now you gone, go figure ♪
♪ So you better not let
nobody else hear it ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]